every once in a while I like a good old
pat robertson's story and since it's
Christmastime or something I thought
that we would do one today so
televangelist Pat Robertson is known for
his online Christianity show I don't
know what else to call it
the 700 club he's now 89 years old he's
doing a show he continues to do his show
he's been doing it a very very long time
and he has often said Oh God told me
this God told me that God told me the
other thing God apparently speaks to Pat
Robertson regularly and a Pat Robertson
thanks to his conversations with God
even if they are one-way conversations
maybe there are many things that Pat
Robertson has learned are demonic so in
the past over the last 10 years we've
heard from Pat Robertson that secondhand
sweaters from goodwill are can be
demonic Ouija boards and yoga can be
demonic Harry Potter and feng shui
are definitely demonic karate horoscopes
can have demons attached the Twilight
series very demonic paintings of Buddha
absolutely demonic TV shows about ghosts
are demonic Halloween is I mean who of
course that's demonic psychics are
demonic young girls who levitate their
friends at sleepovers and even sometimes
adopted children from other countries
can come with demons attached according
to Pat Robertson now it seems as though
God may have played a bit of a dirty
trick on Pat Robertson because for a
very long time now Pat Robertson has
been assuring his audience that don't
worry Donald Trump is not going to get
impeached by the House of
Representatives it won't happen no way
nohow
it seems that Pat Robertson was led
astray maybe by what he heard from God
during prayer take a look at one of a
few examples of Pat Robertson predicting
there will be no impeachment the house
will not vote impeachment there will be
no impeachment they don't have the
courage to do it and there is no way
that they will be there'll be a majority
vote in the United States House of
Representatives to bring forth a bill of
impeachment
the Senate and so forth and my
prediction is it isn't going to happen
they will not have a vote there will be
no impeachment and we'll go forward to
the election I don't believe there will
be an impeachment vote as I said before
I'll say it again
there is not going to be an impeachment
vote in the house that really puts
everybody on record well here's my
fairest prediction one more time the
house does not have the guts to vote
impeachment they will not vote
impeachment they will not vote it they
just mark my word they do not have the
courage to go for the American people
this is all a publicity stunt ladies to
know what I've said it before I'll say
it again there is no way that these
Democrats will dare to vote impeachment
to motive villain impeachment for such a
religious man who takes all of his
problems questions and enquiries to God
it's shocking he was so wrong on this in
a sense isn't it and this actually
reminded me of so I don't know if people
remember but years ago when producer
Lewis was still producer we brought in a
psychic and had her do a live reading of
Lewis and of me a cold reading I guess
we would call it and it was just a
fiasco and of course there were those
including Lewis I think who said even
though psychics are real that was not a
real psychic or whatever and after that
even though I announced we're not doing
any more of this I started getting
emails from so-called psychics saying
hey David I want to go on and prove to
you that psychics are real and and that
I'm a real psychic and every time I've
said to them if you're a psychic
shouldn't you already have known in
advance that I wasn't going to have you
on my show and you could have skipped
emailing me altogether and every single
time they say the same thing that's not
how it works there always has to be some
mystery about how it works and it's
often that way with Pat Robertson either
God works in mysterious ways
or maybe Pat Robertson didn't pray hard
enough for the right answers from God or
something like that but in any case
there it is Pat Robertson apparently not
quite as good at political prophecy well
actually I don't know that he's that
good at any prophecy really but
apparently Pat Robertson just not that
good at making predictions and if you
just to kind of bring this around
because it's been so long since we
talked about Pat a lot of people
probably aren't familiar particularly
our younger viewers and listeners with
how Pat Robertson got started and built
up the 700 club thing
he started it on the from what I recall
caught early contributions of a bunch of
people that he knew personally friends
acquaintances whatever and grew the 700
club into a evangelical Christian
institution with an incredible backstory
that I am not pleased by I don't like it
I don't think it's a good show for
Humanity but it is an interesting story
nonetheless and I encourage you to check
it out probably the 700 club wiki or Pat
the wiki about Pat Robertson would have
the story check it out it is both
interesting compelling and scary all at
the same time I am thrilled to tell you
that today's episode is sponsored in
part by Blink asam / Pakman blink astiz
a really unique service for your phone
tablet and web browser and it is
incredibly useful for people like me who
love books and learning but are busy
blinka steaks the best and most popular
non-fiction books and condenses them
into 15-minute audiobooks I'm sure that
if you're like me you have a very long
list of books that you've been meaning
to read you only have so many hours in
the day and that's why blink astiz so
amazing they take the most important
information the themes the insights from
each book and they distill it into a 15
minute audio book that you can listen to
in one sitting I've listened to a ton of
books on blankets our audience can get a
7 day free trial by going to blink accom
slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I've put a link in the
description I have listened to blinka
spokes about economics about political
science about history about science so
many interesting things and after the
free trial if you like it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month go to blink accom slash
Pakman that's bli n ki st.com /pa k ma n